so somebody sent me this clip from the
internet's favorite personality so let's
go
do you know what girls are more scared
of than losing a man they like they're
more scared of having the man they like
but he doesn't like her anymore so what
will happen if I put a girl in those
kind of scenarios and she doesn't act
right or doesn't make the right choice
what I will do instead of actually
getting rid of her I'll keep her I'll
keep [ __ ] her but I'll [ __ ] her
differ
so instead of there's no kissing anymore
you understand you understand you
understand anymore she's gonna feel it
different yeah and afterwards she's
gonna be like you don't you don't love
me anymore do you there's this going
you've threatened intimacy
and she's gonna get it's no longer
intimate on any level she got [ __ ] and
then afterwards she'd be like trying to
give me a hug I'll be like oh wait wait
I've got to go out and I'm Gonna Change
on such a small level that will hurt her
more than even losing you the problem
the reason guys can't do that is because
if they [ __ ] a [ __ ] again they fall
back in love with a [ __ ] I won't do
that
ain't this the same goofy [ __ ] that a
lot of women will say when they're like
uh yeah if you're not giving you what
you want withhold sex or whatever
girls yeah girls in the same imagine
caring so much about a woman you're even
considering getting rid of that you're
gonna be like let me manipulate her or
like [ __ ] with her feelings so much so
that she falls for me she like it's down
on her knees for me it's like this is
loser [ __ ] but should that woman do
some women do it but that we call them
losers so this is the other side of that
coin oh you're going to get you're not
gonna get none you're gonna sleep on the
couch you're gonna this and that and
that same same
that you don't make the right choices
they punish you
this is they slim your plate on the
table when they serve you they
say same thing sex as a as a man is a
weapon you need to use you have to deny
it you have to give it you gotta give it
good you gotta give it back you gotta
use it right and when I say I said chick
talking bro that's a whole broad talking
that's that's goofy that's a that's a
girl talking bro that's goofy [ __ ]
that's things I've heard women say about
like I'll withhold that from you and
I'll use that against but there's been
scenarios where a girl hasn't acted
quite right over something small not a
big transgression like cheating then
then I continue to see her but my my
demeanor towards her changed and my
demeanor towards her didn't change much
in day-to-day life right but it changed
when we had sex and she smelt it and she
could feel it and it hurt her bad and
she got her ass in line fast he used to
kiss me he used to hug me afterwards
these small things you go to just go to
just go from all that nice [ __ ] to just
[ __ ] her like she but but not in a
good way like she's nothing in a bad way
like she's nothing the Real G's know
what I'm saying there's a difference
yeah there's a difference and you'll
speak to this about it's because in that
moment you have her in her most
vulnerable place that's right that's
right
women women are most programmable
because because all women are programmed
and I want to say this maybe I'll be a
misogynist now let's do it all right
let's do it I said this I said this in
another podcast I believe that men are
more capable of independent thought
because I believe that men are more
evolved for battle and War so if we had
an idea which nobody else agreed with
we're more capable defending it we've
evolved to saying no the sky is blue
it's not green okay pull a sword out
we'll defend our idea women don't have
the capability to defend themselves or
their ideas so they're they're going to
go along with an idea they heard from
somebody else in general right
women are more programmable than men
do you believe that
I think humans are programmable just on
different things it's just different
things it's not it's just manner
programmable on different stuff than
women are but still programmable
everybody's programmable unions it's
been the whole old research and studies
about that I mean just the the the fact
that you're saying yo that we're able to
go alone blah blah women are more
programmable just going to the Army as a
program
going to the Army is you being
programmed to think a certain way being
a whole ass cop is being programmed to
serve certain things and not certain
things in certain certain ways and not
ways and stuff that you might not even
believe and so that you might not even
believe in so I'll give you another one
I'll give you another one how many times
you've seen dudes in relationships who
changed the way that they live the way
that they model their home
Foods live one way before they meet a
girl and change the entire lifestyle
they change how they dress they change
how they look they change how their
homes are run they change the wallpaper
have you ever noticed whenever you go to
a couple's place or a married couple's
place it's majority of the female ideas
in regards to how the place looks yeah
that's why even even you even say like
um yeah who was it who was it you see a
lot of dudes say this stuff where it's
like
um women help pacify men to some degree
whereas like maybe you live this wild
lifestyle you do this and that but as
you meet a woman you start toning this
[ __ ] down yeah
yeah I'll give it to you here's another
one yes might not notice
but you guys are aware that men are far
more susceptible to scams and frauds
than women are
that's another way of being programmed
so this idea that we just go into this
because like here's the thing right I
feel like as a listener when you're
listening to this stuff he says it with
such certainty that you just take the
basis of his foundation for his argument
to be true and then from there all of
his subsequent observations make sense
on top of that there's no data to back
this up there's no it's just his opinion
I wouldn't even say that men are Morris
programmable than women I'm just saying
it's just different things
women are programmable and things as
well shopping and groceries and stuff
like that it's based on all women think
uh the way the shopping is whenever you
go to groceries the way its place is
based on the way women think you know I
mean the publicity sometimes is gear uh
towards women when we talk about girls
reason when we talk about uh hygiene
products and stuff like that
programmable yes publicity publicity
programs man and woman yeah they have
different types of different people for
different types of things you want to
you want to sell cars for certain genre
people you're going to modify it to to
programs I mean even the fact that you
claim that men have changed so much over
the last 45 years as proofs of their
social conditioning and their
programming so right the idea that
people are malleable and that men as a
whole can change you buy into it because
you say yourself is that men and women
have changed so much over the last 45
years so I'm Sent From Another Dimension
I call myself Morpheus saying I'm
hacking The Matrix but you can say it's
a certain Wormhole wherever you want to
call it I'm From Another Dimension and
I'm here to help the young man in the
world it's actually a very dangerous
world view where men have no Duty and no
responsibility the problem with the
world today is that not enough men feel
this Duty and this is a person with a
huge influence a huge Channel trying to
broadcast and convince the world that
you have no innate responsibility as a
man and I disagree with that that's why
I appear from another [ __ ] Dimension
to save all of you top G like a
superhero okay I agree with you you know
I can't say yeah so I can't say it with
one more than the other but it's
definitely not yeah okay it's definitely
a lot oh women are programmable man or
not
I'd say I'd be willing to be like on
different stuff but people are
programmable yeah so all women are
programmed women are programmed they're
either programmed by society as a whole
or if they're with a good man they're
programmed by the good man that's that's
basically where the programming comes
from as a whole so all women are
programmed on some level and uh I think
with with especially during sex that's
when women are most programmable because
they're most vulnerable like if you get
a [ __ ] and she's just about to come so
I agree with him in that within the
confines of a relationship or sex that
um it definitely changes the women a lot
more than I feel the changes men I agree
with them on that point
yeah I would agree that after having sex
with somebody the one who's most likely
going to change in terms of their
behavior and the way they look at you is
going to be a woman yeah I would agree
with that like if you get a [ __ ] and
she's just about to come and you start
saying in her face I'm gonna cheat on
you you [ __ ] [ __ ] and she comes while
you say You're Gonna cheat she's gonna
end up getting horny next time you cheat
I know it sounds crazy yeah that [ __ ]
sounds crazy
that [ __ ] sounds crazy
I'm telling you it's [ __ ] true
operate talking fast he's talking
straight back
the dude sitting around the table also
sound corny as [ __ ] yeah he's talking
about what have you guys tried have you
guys all just taken experimental chances
and be like y'all I'm gonna [ __ ]
cheat on you have you guys all tried
this [ __ ] you know what I like I like
about this I like the fact that Myron
dress is like you know in pajamas when
there's girls around but he dresses up
when there's dudes around like this
boy's nice I do a boys bite it's dress
up it's just it's anyway whatever but
that's your thing is fine it's okay do
your thing
but I think the point that he's making
is like some of the triggers that you
say while they're orgasming might turn
them on the next time doesn't have to be
I'll cheat on you maybe it's just like
your mom looks I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] you would say that's weird
it's fine it's just such random
information to get in but okay there's
ways you can [ __ ] her like she doesn't
mean anything in a way that she enjoys
and ways you can [ __ ] her like she
doesn't mean anything in a way she
doesn't enjoy the G's of the game know
exactly what I'm saying bro and and you
could do that gradually over time if she
ain't acting right you can change the
way you [ __ ] a [ __ ] to make her start
to get insecure about he doesn't
actually care but he doesn't actually
like me and now it'll shock him you have
moves you can make but you gotta be
about you're gonna be perspicacious you
gotta pick up see when I hear stuff like
this this is the stuff that makes me
look at him sideways the rest of the
stuff I don't really care about like I
said the high value made this it sounds
corny and if you're being honest with
yourself and it's a woman like all these
guys will be like oh [ __ ] talk if a
woman had said the same [ __ ] you would
look at her like she's a loser you would
you would
yeah but men and women are different
you're engaging in the same form of like
manipulation and emotional investment
that these loser ladies do when they do
this kind of like withholding of sex to
punish a man it's corny do it if you
want to do it if you want to be that
invested into it but I just couldn't
imagine being at that point with a woman
where I'm like how am I going to teach
her a lesson
all right I'm I'ma stop cuddling and
kissing her I'm gonna still [ __ ] her
then just move on bro she got that point
where you have to do all this
manipulation to motor keep it pushing
I don't know
go ahead both of them just but I can see
I can see the the boasting the the ego
and everything and stuff I could see
like you know it feels good to you know
feel like you're you're Superior then or
whatever whatnot I I can understand I
don't understand well they feel they
feel they talk like they are a superior
to women yeah and they feel that they
are exactly so I can understand that
they go in the same sentiment like it
goes in that grain right so I mean that
that's not that's that that's to be
expected from people that think that you
know are superior than other people but
um other than that it's girl [ __ ] to me
that's and I say you know what it's not
even girl [ __ ] cause guys do that [ __ ]
too I'm gonna take that back it's not
girl [ __ ] it's very immature you got
some [ __ ] you got some [ __ ] you got to
solve it's either I talk it out and if I
don't want to deal with you I'm not
gonna like try to play no if if [ __ ] is
not working [ __ ] is not working I'm not
gonna try to uh but you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] you different to feel some type of
way that's
fast
fast corny that's immature to me but you
know you wanted to have power it's like
having the power that you never had or
whatever whatnot you have to show that
you have power you have to show that you
are in control that's very controlling
[ __ ] a very
trying to play games like that I'm gonna
kiss her different yo
and it also it's very exhausting
yeah it's exhausting to be like okay I'm
gonna do this yo maybe for them though
there's something to say it's so natural
like they don't gotta think about it Dan
do you if that's how you be and you cool
with that then do you boo boo I just
couldn't imagine wasting anything
the high value and you got all these
ladies throw away move on to the next
one if you got so many options but
someone that really don't like that have
options that really doesn't give a [ __ ]
like that doesn't give a [ __ ] doesn't
say that he doesn't give a [ __ ] because
the more that you say that you don't
give a [ __ ] the more you kind of look
like you give a [ __ ] but also acts
accordingly okay you know what yeah I
know that's not happening next and moves
on to the next one but you don't want to
be with a ping and then you hold on to
the thing that's weird d That's corny
but whatever